judging by the number of people
foregoing masks at large sporting events
here ontario seems to be over-covered
however the numbers show that we're well
into the sixth wave with a recent spike
in cases adding to the estimated five to
six million ontarians who contracted
omicron since december
the difference from earlier in the
pandemic hospitalization numbers have
stayed low
still one recent statistic is drawing a
fair amount of attention for a time
reinfection was considered rare yet over
the past six months almost 12 000
ontarians have caught covid for a second
time the majority between the ages of 20
and 59. i think a lot of people were
lulled into believing that you know if
they caught covet they would be fine
forever
and the reality is
there's a few things working against
that for one he says the virus keeps
mutating so antibodies from one variant
won't work as well for another also only
47 percent of canadians are triple
vaxxed and while it was originally
believed catching covid could provide
years of immunity recent studies have
shown four to five months is more
accurate
we
have seen that there is a benefit from
being immunized against ba2 there's
still strong protection levels it's just
that over time your protection levels do
fade from around 90 percent protection
against ba2 to 80 to 70 to 60 over time
on social media the reinfection numbers
have stoked the discord over vaccines
frustrating doctors who argue explaining
immunity is about more than one
statistic
the immune system is very very
complicated unfortunately it's not as
simple as you got it you'll never get it
again studies are being conducted on
reinfection but any real data will take
time to collect leaving much of canada
in covet status quo microlight global
news toronto